depuis aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur
the world ends à foncière version
halloween du jeu attendez c'était plus
halloween
ok c'est parti à oui oui effectivement
c'est bien la version halloween avec des
bonnes grosses toile d'araignée et ou
alors si mais je vois bien le mec qui va
entrer chez lui au bout d'un moment et
nous notre but c'est de cambrioler sa
foutue maison ok même les lampes se
déguisent
comment je vois la liste yanis d'objets
volés quand je la vois et voilà c'est
comme quand on fait les courses on
oublie toujours là [ __ ] de liste ce
que pour la cambrure lâché karam
horrible je la vois avant là c'est bon
une caméra digitale une tour
d'ordinateur sanon à banon il faut un
ordinateur fixe avec un ordinateur
portable on n'en veut pas bien mais
c'est mes gags locaux allaient déco
comme ça non mais sans déconner je
refuse de cambolle cette maison quoi
j'en ai juste envie de me barrer alors à
micro-ondes au pl ace à vos chères à
micro-ondes ok vous rigolez pas puis ça
permet de faire des petits plats des
petits plats marine midi et tout merde
il va arriver il va arriver faut que je
me tire près ça veut dire marque doit
d'ici lui car je croyais live par cette
porte ils arrivent en voiture comme ça
aux grosses ferrari avait des bitchy
j'ai tout leur nez dans son line up a
d'ailleurs on va prendre ça allez à
bientôt à oui c'est vrai là il ya un
coffre il me semble au maire c'est quoi
le code c'est qu'il vient d'acheter le
coffret qu'elle laissait le code par
défaut non alors oui la tour
d'ordinateur attendant ce serait bien
trouver la tour d'ordinateur s'il vous
plaît j'ai la voix complètement hs je
peux paquet si je le vois je vais pas
pouvoir crier comme caché là dedans ou
ce mec a de l'argent partout au saas est
un ordinateur on prend pas l'écran non
ok juste la tourte je comprendrai jamais
pourquoi ce mec vol que la moitié des
chaudes c'était la pendule cascino gros
parole à ceux récoltés ces médias
mystique
bon je me barre le mec va arriver
oh non mais on pas la voie s'il vous
plaît eh ben c'est bien la version
halloween un [ __ ] what the beat qui se
passe quoi dans la maison sans déconner
y'a pas toi c'est ça emmerde
mais se passe quoi là whaou non mais
c'est quoi ce n'est pas ta maison du
diable ou alors des lampes [ __ ] d'un
[ __ ] de maison du théâtre ça explique
bordel tout il n'aura jamais avec la
faune et m'ont jamais m'entends tu as ya
le vase hop je veux le vase au passage à
bientôt à non à aa
tu ne m'auras jamais on peut jouer à
charenton que tu peux ok stop non non
non je me cachais dans la voix on va se
cacher dans un ballet c'est qu'on n'a
pas tort
un mois je veux te rentrer de ne pas
rentrer dedans j'ai pris un moment que
le pouvoir du bon sens avec nous et que
seul on se protège de l'ingestion de
passer un mec avec un pull bear comme ça
oui bonjour je m'appelle françoise caron
la faucheuse qui arrivait lapins poules
des râteaux choses hein on doit s'enfuir
messieurs dames
il nous reçoit à voler une caméra non
mais j'ai fermé la porte de la chambre
de l'extérieur comme pour lui indiquer
qu'il fallait me tuer moi et pas aller
voir dans la championne est quelqu'un la
faucheuse vous appris votre âme parce ou
de bonbons sinon j'ai des oreilles de
lapin ce comme tu veux alors du coup
l'analyste a changé une montre un album
un blender pourquoi ce mec t'as pas pris
un énorme sac voilà je fais pas tu vas
chez go sport france avec le plus cher
le plus volumineux dans lequel il met
tout ce qu'ils trouvent bordel comme ça
hop ils pouvaient mettre cette télé dans
le sac et tous mes ouailles aux anneaux
le seul tout mignon cette déco succès
voilà c'est ça ils ont découpé une
feuille a3 sont mignons ils me font du
bien voilà blessa à oui d'accord
carrément hockey à tanger tétouan
blain de l'apport d'objets comme ça il
pourra pas venir le combat mais tout ce
qu'on a un choix qu'il apparaît dans la
maison lui c'est plus comme dans les
versions de base comme j'ai dis ou
françois arrivé en plus aux verts comme
ça bonjour quelqu'un de cambriole
oh je suis généreux prend tous placés
juste deux mois thomas hall tablettes
il s'en fout hockey et ben alors la
tablette qui va servir à barricader mon
gars avec ayo et suit sa barricade mieux
qu'avec à ios est regardée en afrique
[ __ ] de barricades comme l'écart entre
une
montres de poche bah voilà juste là une
bouteille de parfum se doit c'est demain
ça c'est quoi ça c'est de l'eau bénite
ça alors c'est sûr la faucheuse
attendent aurait essayé je sens les
chèques mais on va essayer quand même ok
il arrivé là
la faucheuse et là on a l'eau bénite qui
est juste pour la porte qu'on récupère
voilà on l'a avec nous que parce que l
a2 en élixir peut-être un élixir
hydratant pour femmes filaments gobain
auderset de l'eau bénite quand même tu
refais une embuscade ya un regard ya de
la lumière ici bénite ministre y at il
une faucheuse dans l'air il ya eu 41
points au fait puisqu'à la base n'a fait
de marica dont je tiens à dire quand
même aux combats ni dans ton cul ça n'a
rien fait ça n'a rien fait la semoy
envie je m'en vais ok on a fermé on peut
aller ou pas loupé à je me suis enfui
comme un gros coup mais non il nous
manquait juste la moitié de la lisent au
moment où on est vivants ok on a notre
âme un rien tôt puisque les coûts
inutiles
si quelqu'un est réalisateur je le vois
mon cv d'acteurs portrait d'une femme
via la femme vers le blender daft punk
da funk
c'est quoi ce bordel salut watts une âme
dans une jarre ico brûle une maison et
sur sa liste y met une âme dans une
jarre
ce mec est carrément chelou en fait on
joue la faucheuse finalement offert
jumeaux et l'autre faucheuse qui est
venu buter tu es hors d'état de choc là
actuellement voilà ça ne va pas du tout
alors qu'il est lui il va me suivre
pendant longtemps fait qu'on l'a fauché
à vouloir prendre mon âme elle va
prendre lui c'est une âme ça tu veux te
sucreries ou pareils on a une là bon
alors tu vas arrêter me faire chier dans
un premier temps tu vas répondre à mes
questions à partir de batterie si je
vais dans toi comme ça n'est pas
possible ce type de bien voir une
feuille à 88,44 à les baous toi ça
brille oh merde c'est pas bon ça se sent
pas bon ça sent pas bon on se tire elle
est où ma petite âme
elle est où j'ai perdu mon âme c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'autre peut
veiller sur moi les hommes cette
corbeille mouchoirs salle c'est airbus à
air assure nous c'est l'arbre sacré
arbre sacré à la renverse
[ __ ] de mer mais si on ne peut plus
faire ses courses tranquille bordel moi
je passais la [ __ ] concurrence mont
garin il n'y a pas eu ou pas bien batta
non non non on a dit pas dans le placard
oualalou placard je le ferme tu arrêtes
tu t'en vas
c'est interdit tu peux aller five c'est
ça eye-fi iphone voilà battant au elles
sont violentes fc puis il ressemble plus
écoute pour un blizzard bataille tourne
highfive tu arrêtes maintenant high five
voilà ça va j'ai deux amours ou de fait
la taille des maps hommes d'adrie tu me
laisse en paix auquel tient faut lui
donner faut pas le manger mais quel est
le petit gros qu'on joue dans le jeu
bordelais
mais alors la alors là alors la une
montre une bague en diamant et une
guitare
et si on a ça on a tous nos fans et on
peut se battre cette maison en paix et
pas besoin d'une chemise pour toiser
renonce à sanandaj pas non il y avait
des billets mais tu voudras des billets
dans cet argent [ __ ] c'est dingue ces
[ __ ] d'abba celui-ci avait une
chambre de bébé sous berceau il y aura
un billet de 100 euros ou encore que
l'aérien on s'est fait arnaquer ya juste
une [ __ ] de tablettes c'est même pas
une tablette d'asus ses tablettes aux
formes savait qu'on trouve à jouer clos
mais et compagnie les tablettes sur
lequel tu apprends la femme et notamment
la guitare en eau ltp on se tire on vend
baiia du champagne base il met toi bien
faucheuse bats toi bien envasé a aucun
problème
nous on est sam ce soir au quai entre
amène pas entre deux livres ils ont
caché le monde joue demain mondialement
olalala sous les oreillers
oh la la la montre était caché sous des
oreilles non elles vont près de cette
maison ce cas un moins bon voire les
kwassa se connaissent c'est comme si
pour trouver la guitare fallait que
j'aille rien et dont les toilettes quoi
et là il manque juste la bague en
diamant campus elle doit être bien
minuscule comme ça là qu'est ce qui se
passe là si l'on ophrenie level max et
si la bague en diamant était au doigt de
la faucheuse
du coup vous vous trouvez une hache ou
des ciseaux pour découper son copain de
doigts fripés celle qu'ils ont pris
l'apéro et qui a fait tomber sa bague
dans les chips
non mais attends on a tous là
a sortie est juste là non on va narguer
la faucheuse monga faucheuse à l'eau non
faucheuse ça va sur les connais je suis
inquiet pour est là qu est ce qui se
passe mais elle est où on l'a largué on
n'a pas tant que ça tabac poker mais
carrément en train de croiser savent a
fait une crise de diabète qui tu fais là
oh merde merde tient va faire du vélo
pour te divertir un peu hop on repart de
la maison avec un total de quarante
mille dollars et un traumatisme
psychologique à vie parce qu'on a vu une
[ __ ] trop chaud et ça fait de nous un
voleur professionnel
bravo bravo à tous je porte la couronne
au nom de tous bien joué félicitations
vraiment oui c'est notre couronne
s'oppose un problème moi un peu quand
même
et voilà gens c'est la foi c'est bien
sûr s'organise t elle j'avais déjà loupé
l'édition spéciale doit elle qui l'a vu
l'année dernière et là je ne pouvais pas
passer à côté de l'édition d'halloween
bas savoir regarder et surtout que
j'avais dans ce nouvel et ocho tout le
monde
pis ou la mise à jour mais la couronne
voilà watts la fin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]